in the last video where we generalized
the linear consumption function I said I
said that the tax the total amount of
taxes the aggregate taxes are constant
all of these two were constants right
here so you can kind of merge them into
a constant that ended up being our our
independent variable intercept right
over here but YouTube user nil soar 1337
asks a very interesting and good
question
well aren't taxes in some way a function
of aggregate income in most in most
modern economies people pay a percentage
of their income or in general tax the
tax base grows as aggregate income or as
GDP grows so is it appropriate to make
this constant so the simple answer is it
depends on how carefully you want to
model it in some cases you might just
say well let's just assume that this is
a bulk tax we're just trying to
understand one aspect of it and you will
see that in some economics courses or
some economics textbooks the other way
is you could actually model it a little
bit more realistic you could say hey
taxes really are a function of aggregate
income we could say that T really is
going to be equal to some tax rate I'll
write that as a lowercase T times
aggregate times aggregate income and in
the place like the US this might be
close to the 30 percent of aggregate
income or 20 percent whatever it might
be of aggregate income is what is going
to go for taxes and if you do it this
way and you substitute back into this
you can actually get an expression of
for consumption in terms of aggregate
income that takes into factor takes into
factor that takes into consideration the
idea that taxes are function of
aggregate income and just to do that
algebraically we can rewrite this
expression up here so you have
consumption aggregate consumption is
equal to is equal to my marginal
propensity to consume times aggregate
income times aggregate income plus plus
autonomous consumption the amount that
would be consumed no matter what - minus
the marginal propensity to consume shows
up again and then instead of writing T
instead of writing T right over here I'm
going to write I'm going to write
lowercase T times y so the tax rate
times aggregate
so times the tax rate times aggregate
times aggregate income so I just took
this instead of writing uppercase T I
look I wrote lowercase T times aggregate
income and they should be the same thing
but now we've expressed T as a function
of aggregate income and now we can merge
both of these these are something times
aggregate income so we can combine those
two terms so this one and this one right
over here if we factor out if we factor
out a common factor of C one times y we
get let me write it this way actually
let me just combine them first so that
the algebra doesn't confuse you so we
get C is equal to is equal to c1 times y
so marginal propensity to consume times
aggregate income now I'm going to write
this one minus the marginal propensity
to consume times I'll switch the order
here well let me not switch the order
times the tax rate not just the
aggregate total tax value but the actual
tax rate times times aggregate income
times aggregate income so that's those
two terms there and then we're just left
with the autonomous consumption so plus
the autonomous consumption and now over
here we have a common factor of we can
factor out a c1 and and the y or
essentially the marginal propensity to
consume and the aggregate income and so
this is just algebraic manipulation
right over here we get aggregate
consumption is equal to is equal to
let's see we could write this as C 1
times 1 minus T 1 minus T times y times
y you can multiply this out to verify if
you multiply it all out then the first
term is C 1 so C 1 times 1 times y is
this right over here and C 1 times
negative T times y is this term right
over here and then you're left with then
you are left with your autonomous
consumption and this actually makes a
lot of sense because when you write it
like this when you write it like this
you can look at this term right over
here what is this term right over here
well 1 minus the tax rate times
aggregate income if the tax rate is 30%
then
one minus 30% is going to be 70 percent
70 percent times aggregate income that's
essentially what people get in their
pockets this is this whole term right
over here is essentially a disposable
income disposable disposable income
right over here so we could actually if
we wanted to write this as some other
variable we can just put that variable
right over there and say it's disposable
income and then actually becomes a very
simple thing to graph so we could graph
this two different ways if we wanted to
write it a function of aggregate income
of aggregate income we would we would
graph it we would graph it like this now
when we express it this way taxes as a
function of aggregate income now our
vertical intercept so this is aggregate
consumption our vertical intercept is
this term right over here so that is C
naught and our slope is all of this
business and so the slope of our line
the slope slope is going to be C 1 times
1 minus T and this right over here the
independent variable is aggregate income
another option we could set some other
variable to say well we could say
disposable income let me call it Y Y
disposable is equal to 1 minus T times y
and then we could write this so it's
essentially equal to this business right
over there so then we can rewrite the
consumption function as aggregate
consumption is equal to the marginal
propensity to consume times disposable
income times disposable income plus some
level of autonomous consumption plus
plus some level of autonomous
consumption and this actually takes us
back to the basics this takes us back to
our very original situation here where
we had some autonomous consumption plus
our marginal propensity to consume times
disposable income and if we wanted to
plot it this way as a function of
disposable income not aggregate income
then it would look like this
so this is consumption and now this is
an aggregate income this is disposable
income disposable income which is the
same thing as 1 minus the tax rate times
aggregate income now still our vertical
intercept
depth is see not and our lines slope is
the marginal propensity to consume so
this is see one just like that so all of
these are completely valid consumption
functions and I thank nil sorr 1337 for
bringing up a topic that actually was a
cause of confusion for me because it
really does depend because I thought the
way he or she originally thought about
the problem is that well taxes are a
function and a lot of econ books tend to
treat this as a constant and that is
actually just an assumption they make to
often simplify the calculations but if
they don't want to make that assumption
you can still show that though you can
still show that it is a linear function
of that consumption is still a linear
function of aggregate income